it's one of the most hyped games that
never existed half-life 2 episode 3
billed as the conclusion to the
half-life saga it was originally
supposed to hit the shelves before
Christmas of 2007 then developer valve
delayed it while they expanded it into a
full-length sequel half-life 3 and
delayed it and delayed it and well fans
are still waiting here's a look at why
we never got to play half-life 3 the
hype is too big since the original
announcement of half-life 2 episode 3
valve has released several blockbuster
hit games including portal and portal 2
Team Fortress 2 and left for dead but
despite the success of these titles the
game that eventually became known as
half life 3 was never rolled out to the
masses
instead earning the top slot among the
most famous pieces of vaporware and as
time went on the company line on episode
3 from creator gabe newell evolved from
firm commitment to vague mentions to
complete refusals to comment whatsoever
the main thing that we're working on
right now after we get the orange box
out the door is going to be episode 3 so
we can finish off this trilogy in a
reddit AMA in January 2017 Newell said
that it's hard for me to look at them as
anything other than a series of things I
regret that doesn't sound promising the
main writer retired in early 2016
Marc Laidlaw the main writer and
creative voice behind the entire
half-life series retired from valve
after 18 years with the company when
asked what his departure from valve
meant for the completion of half-life 3
Laidlaw answered I don't and can't
entirely know half-life is fully owned
by valve it came into existence before
my arrival where valve may choose to
take it in the future is not in my hands
internal politics according to an
anonymous valve employee who spoke with
Game Informer the dynamic way the
employees choose projects contributed to
half-life 3 never getting off the ground
developers artists story writers and
other team members can literally take
their desk and move it to whatever
project interests than the most this
means internal politics can really make
or break a game the anonymous source
estimates that various iterations of
half-life 3
have been in development as early as
2005 I've heard that some teams have had
two or three people working on it and
they eventually ran into a wall and some
teams may have gotten up to 30 or 40
people before it was scrapped some
people I don't want to mention names
were excited about their projects
they've had some different thoughts
about what it should be every time a
halflife project gets some gravity and
then collapses it becomes harder for the
next one to start up steam bath valve
isn't seriously in the business of
making video games anymore and they
haven't been for some time with the
exception of the lab a set of free mini
games that shipped in 2016 with the HTC
vive valve hasn't actually created a
title since dota 2 back in 2013 it's
worth noting that many of Valve's
franchises including left4dead
and portal started out in the hands of
other companies companies which valve
then acquired similarly counter-strike
dota 2 day of defeat and Team Fortress
all started as mods mods which valve
then acquired do you notice a pattern
here Valve's only game franchise that
they conceptualized and developed from
the very beginning was the half-life
saga which launched the company into the
big leagues since then they've moved on
to more profitable ventures such as
steam while valve doesn't publicly
release financial data in 2011 a Forbes
article estimated that through steam
valve controlled between 50 and 70
percent of the downloadable PC game
market and that they take 30% of every
sale on Steam for themselves that means
in 2016 alone they may have brought in
as much as eight hundred and forty
million dollars distributing games they
didn't spend a dime to develop meanwhile
it's estimated that the half-life
franchise has generated only about twice
that much over the past 19 years
combined at a much higher cost to the
company simple math says that half-life
3 may literally not be worth their time
or effort the most important character
died okay at this point some of you are
yelling at your screen Gordon is still
alive you fool
but Eli Vance not Gordon Freeman was
actually the most important character of
the half-life saga he was essentially a
living MacGuffin who drove the entire
plot think about it in half-life 2 your
first objective is to go meet Eli Vance
then when he gets kidnapped your
objective is to rescue him
but then he gets captured again and so
you have to go rescue him again I've
been on the line with Alex her father
has been captured he lives is
indispensable to the liberation when you
finally free him the game ends before he
tells you anything and you spend the
next two episodes basically tracking him
down yet again to find out what his big
stupid secret is which he still doesn't
tell you before he dies without Eli as a
focus for your efforts there's a huge
hole in the franchise and if valve has
figured out a way to fill it they
certainly aren't saying say never at
this point it looks as though the only
thing that could convince valve to make
another half-life is if the fans really
really want it the fans of the franchise
inside valve itself that is that's what
Newell said in a 2015 podcast
the only reason we'd go back and do like
a super classic kind of product is if a
whole bunch of people just internally at
valve said you know they wanted to do it
we know exactly what that means
half-life 3 is never going to happen
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our youtube channel
let's check out all this cool stuff we
know you'll love to
[Music]